thousands of china's most powerful
politicians are gathering in beijing on
friday
to chart the country's roadmap for the
next 5 to 15 years
the annual national people's congress or
npc
was postponed last year following the
coronavirus outbreak
this year covert 19 cases are under
control and analysts say
president xi jinping will be touting an
image of triumph
as well as consolidating his power
he has been establishing his power
through political and military
achievements
in the future he will focus on competing
with other superpowers
he plans china's political future like
an emperor
strengthening loyalty to the chinese
communist party is a priority
beijing is preparing for the party
centenary in july
during the congress china's leaders will
release their annual work report
outlining economic targets beijing is
expected to encourage domestic
consumption
and continue to push for a more
prosperous society
to do this they will need to address the
challenges of a widening wealth gap and
an
ageing population a gdp goal is also
usually set though this was skipped last
year because of uncertainties around the
pandemic
and some expect china's defense spending
to be accelerated
especially given recent tensions with
taiwan and in the south china sea
china's strained relationship with the
united states is another focal point
beijing had hoped to reset ties with
washington
but u.s president joe biden is
continuing the tough stance taken by his
predecessor
from their perspective it's been
disappointing they see a lot of the same
rhetoric a lot of the same goals
and ends methods means
that were employed by the trump
administration internationally beijing
is facing increasing criticism over its
treatment of muslim uighurs
as well as political reforms in hong
kong it's expected to tighten its grip
over the territory and pass laws to
ensure only those loyal to beijing
are able to hold office the national
security law
banning subversion was unveiled at last
year's npc
dozens were arrested under the law this
week for holding a primary vote ahead of
elections
meanwhile environmental policymakers
will be watching for further action
on climate change the government is
expected to set targets for reducing
carbon emissions
moving towards xi's goal of making china
carbon neutral
by 2060 katrina u al jazeera beijing